لدي سؤال لدي سؤال
لك، لقد قلت أنك لا تريد
الرياضيين البيلاروسيين والروس أه في
الأولمبياد آسف كنت أطرح
سؤالاً على الوزيرة، إنها
وزيرة الرياضة، أسألها وهي لا تفعل ذلك.  لا
تريد أن يشارك رياضيون روس أو أفضل من الرياضيين الروس
في الألعاب الأولمبية
أو الأحداث الرياضية الدولية، لكن هل شعرت
بنفس الطريقة بعد غزو الولايات المتحدة للعراق،
ماذا عن أفغانستان، ماذا عن كندا،
ماذا عن القوات الكندية بعد أن
قصفنا رياضيي الألباكان بعد أن قصفنا
أه ليبيا أو أفغانستان
عذرًا  أنا، لماذا لا تجيب على
السؤال، إنه سؤال بسيط حقًا
أرسله الوزير، إنه
سؤال بسيط حقًا، لماذا ماذا عن
الرياضيين الإسرائيليين، إسرائيل لديها احتلال لمدة 50 عامًا،
واحتلال لمدة 50 عامًا لأراضي فلسطين
في دولة الفصل العنصري،
ماذا عن الحظر  الرياضيون الإسرائيليون
يشكرونكم